تصدر اسم الاسير المقدسي احمد مناصره
منصات التواصل في فلسطين عقب قراري محكمه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تمديد عزله سته اشهر
اضافيه رغم وضعه الصحي الخطير
وابلغ اسم الحريه لاحمد مناصره استذكر
مبردون محطات طفوله الاسير مناصره الذي
اعتقله الاحتلال في السن الثالث عشر
وقارنوا بين صوره حديثه له واخرى عند
بدايه اعتقاله وملامحه التي كبرت بين
جدران الزنزانه ناشط على مواقع التواصل
قال شايفين الفرق بين الصورتين تخيلوا ان
هذا التغير كامل صار لاحمد مناصره في داخل
سجون الاحتلال طبعا الصوره الجديده يبتسم
فيها ووراء هذه الابتسامه وجع والم وحزن
وقهر من انتهت طفولته في اول يوم سجن نراه
الان شابا ونحتسبه صابرا على مصابه
وفي تعليقها على صورته قالت احدى المغردات
هي
الحيره تفتش عن اجابات اضعناها احمد يشكو
الاما في معدته بسبب الاكل الذي لا يرقى
ان يقدم لانسان الحريه لاحمد مناصره نزع
الطفوله الشعب يريد تحرير الاسير بينما
قالت فاطمه في تغريده على تويتر ايضا
اجرام الاحتلال ووحشيته تكمن في سنين احمد
فالاسر